Nancy Pelosi bad person or worst person
we all know this broad has been at the
forefront of this anti waterboarding
crusade of course at first she played it
off like she was horrified when she
found out about it recently
waterboarding porno that's awful who and
then everyone discovered that she was
there for the 2002 briefing and knew
about it all along please there's no
lies yeah so what does good old main
sickens do rather than admit it she
claims she's been Missal by the Bush
administration in the CIA they all
bamboozled me really because Pelosi I
remember for years the implications you
made about George W Bush George Bush's
mildly [ __ ] yeah are you saying
that's changed you're even dumber than I
thought but what do you expect from a
dame who said that the enforcement of
our immigration laws is unamerican a
lady who holds a title of having had her
actions publicly condemned by the Pope
the Pope's a jerk mm-hmm and above all
else a lady who looks like the Joker
it's all a part of the plan and while I
don't know this last one for a fact it's
been reported that she roams alleyways
looking for places to commit acts of
evil
here's the deal Pelosi needs to resign
either a she genuinely doesn't remember
the 2002 CIA briefings because she's
senile sorry toots Botox won't keep the
brain young or be she is lying and
considering that she's accusing the CIA
of deliberately misleading her
essentially calling members of our armed
forces liars I'm inclined to believe the
latter what do you think should Pelosi
resign let me know the truth is a big
part of this waterboarding debate is
leftists accusing our troops of being
lying scumbags we know what
waterboarding is we know who it's
performed and we know that members of
the United States Armed Services do not
torture tell the liberal however that
waterboarding lasts a mere seconds
procession and they all say well we
can't really know about that you're
right we can't but when it comes down to
it I'm inclined to give the men and
women of the United States military the
benefit of the doubt liberal hags like
Nancy Pelosi don't see it that way
despite their claims support of our
troops so Nancy you need to resign or
the people will most likely forcefully
give you the boot and God knows there
are a lot of folks out there who would
like to do a lot more than that to you
[Music]
Oh shout you'll bag
it would be good times